la saint patrick oui c'est la bière oui
c'est la fête mais saint-patrick c'est
avant tout un saint est donc une fête
chrétienne
en 1971 les airs landais de paris nous
ramène au caractère religieux de la
célébration à l'église soit bien avant
l'arrivée de ces irlandais saint patrick
à tisser des liens avec la france
il aurait fait son éducation
ecclésiastique à auxerre avant d'arriver
à cannes sur l'île saint-honorat en
témoigner cette cérémonie en son honneur
en 1961 la cérémonie de cette année
revêt un caractère particulier plus
solennelle que d'habitude car on fait
également le 1500e anniversaire de la
mort de saint patrice ou 5 patrick qui
vécut dans ces lieux avant d'aller
évangéliser l'irlande
à l'autre bout de la france en 1981 la
saint-patrick c'est un moment de
communion et des changes c'est
l'occasion pour les bretons de célébrer
leur amitié avec leurs cousins irlandais
chez leurs cousins d'irlande
je me sens ici chez moi comme toute
irlandaise sans en bretagne chez lui
outre atlantique la saint patrick est
une grande fête célébrée depuis le
xviiie siècle à new york plus grandes
villes irlandaises du monde comme on
disait dans les années 70 ses cornemuses
et majorettes sur la 5e avenue
rendez vous coquin irlandais de la côte
est des états unis d'accepter cette
célébration en grande pompe va même
s'imposer en irlande dans les années 90
ce que regrette l'ancien premier
ministre
garrett fitzgerald en 1984 il crée et
fabrique et qui ont la priorité ici sont
venus ici avec le prat avec l'odeur leur
musique et les majorettes tous comme
cela
en revanche côté boissons les américains
n'ont rien à apprendre aux irlandais la
bière brune ou pas reste aujourd'hui
l'élément indispensable d'une bonne
saint patrick en france notamment où la
fête n'a plus grand chose à voir avec le
saint patron qui a évangélisé l'irlande
[Musique]